bal à la présidente de la commission des
affaires sociales madame la rapporteure
charge off line glee days donnent et
messieurs les les sénateurs je suis
heureux de clore avec vous aujourd'hui
ce chapitre prom parlementaire pardon
portant sur cette proposition de loi
tendant à prévenir les usages dangereux
du protoxyde d'azoté
je souhaite avant toute chose remercier
chaleureusement son auteur la sénatrice
valérie létard dont l'engagement et la
maîtrise auront permis de mettre ce
sujet sur la table d'en faire un
véritable objet politique et donc
d'aboutir à un texte qui rapidement
pourra produire de plaintes est utile fm
je me permet également de saluer la
présence
la députée valérie six qui a également
opéré sur ce texte et je crois que nous
pouvons saluer aussi l'intelligence
collective la collaboration importante
utile efficace entre le sénat et
l'assemblée nationale
alors je sais que les habitants des
régions les plus touchées par le
phénomène d'usagé détourné du protoxyde
d azote sont nombreux à attendre avec
impatience l'entrée en vigueur de cette
loi je sais qu'à tourcoing et d'entre
eux dans d'autres villes on ne connaît
que trop bien les ravages que peut
causer ce geste d'apparence anodine qui
consiste à aspirer une petite quantité
de gaz sus d'un banal contenant un geste
qui reproduit deux trois dix fois
parfois des douzaines de fois puis en
effet causer chez son auteur des
problèmes extrêmement grave physique et
neurologiques
ce produit de consommation courante qui
est utile à certains professionnels ou à
certains cuistots amateurs souffre
aujourd'hui d'une bien mauvaise
réputation
faut dire que la documentation était
étoffé sur ces détournements
on l'a vu utilisé dans des bars dans des
soirées étudiantes dans des fêtes
foraines on l'a vu vendu par des
buralistes ou facilement accessibles sur
internet dans des emballages dont le
marketing ne laissait
pas de place au doute quant à l' usage
qui en serait fait on a vu des mineurs
en consommer parfois encouragés par des
adultes inconscients des risques voix
l'insouciance qui frôle la mise en
danger d'autrui
il était devenu insupportable pour les
responsables politiques pour les
autorités sanitaires d'assister à une
telle déconnexion entre les
comportements des individus et les
risques avérés
je rappelle à ce titre que le ministère
de la santé a publié deux communiqués de
presse qui alertait sur les risques liés
à cet usage détourné en novembre 2019
puis en juillet 2020 à l'occasion de la
publication des données la nsm et de
l'inde cesse campagne d'information et
de réduction des risques avait par
ailleurs été lancée pour toucher
directement non seulement les
consommateurs y compris les plus jeunes
mais aussi les acteurs de terrain
associations collectivités locales
encadrants et personnes en lien avec les
jeunes
bien sûr il fallait que cela
s'accompagne d'un changement législatif
et en ce sens cette proposition de loi a
été plus que bienvenu plus que
nécessaire à un moment important tout
son parcours plaide d'ailleurs en sa
faveur
si le temps a pu paraître long depuis
son premier examen ici même l'émotion
avec madame la sénatrice
la faute n'est pas à chercher une fois
n'est pas coutume du couté d'éventuelles
dissensions politiques les avis au
contraire ont été très largement
partagée sur l'opportunité d'avancer et
globalement sur les termes des mesures à
mettre en oeuvre
sénat et assemblée je l'évoquais tout à
l'heure ont chacun apporté leur
contribution à ce texte contribution que
le gouvernement a estimé parfaitement
utile et et cohérente des délits précis
ont été créés des peines adaptées ont
été prévus des situations et des lieux
précis sont ciblés ce texte est
aujourd'hui équilibrée et ce à double
titre
j'ai eu l'occasion de le rappeler le
partager avec vous en commission la
semaine passée il maintient évidemment
pleinement l'autorisation de
consommation de ce produit d'un produits
d'usagé courant n'est ni un stupéfiant
ni un produit toxique mais en contrôle
en même temps précisément les usages
des tournées qui peut en être fait ils
portent par ailleurs un message puissant
de prévention et de protection des
mineurs et accorde en même temps une
attention particulière à la
responsabilisation des majeures ce volet
de prévention que je viens d'évoquer est
évidemment incontournable
nombreux d'entre vous en commission la
semaine dernière aux affaires sociales
elle avait soulevé avec des acteurs
comme l'âme il décale agence nationale
de sécurité du médicament et des
produits de santé et l'observatoire
pardon français des drogues et des
toxicomanies des travaux fondamentaux
sont menées pour sensibiliser les
publics les plus jeunes aux risques
éventuels auxquels ils s'exposent
avec de telles pratiques parents amis
équipes éducatives toutes et tous
doivent également en être informé cette
prévention doit également se faire
vis-à-vis d'autres produits car les
mésusages se déplace régulièrement vers
d'autres produits par effet de mode ou
du fait de l'interdiction de l'accès
justement aux produits incriminés
les pouvoirs publics sont et resteront
pleinement mobilisés sur ces enjeux
autour du ministre des solidarités de la
santé olivier ferrand et via un réseau
puissant structurés notamment par les
agences régionales de santé
je rappellerai d'ailleurs pour conclure
que des dispositifs dead sont à
disposition des jeunes de leur entourage
et du public en général car la loi n'est
jamais stigmatisante aller fait avant
tout pour protéger et pour accompagner
les publics à risque ou en difficulté il
ne faut donc pas hésiter à se saisir de
ces différents outils en cas de
questions qui à deux difficultés liées à
la consommation de produits de drogue je
pense évidemment aux consultations
jeunes consommateurs cjc qui propose un
service d'accueil d'écouté de conseil et
d'orientation qui est assuré par des
professionnels des addictions qui est
dédié aux jeunes
c'est entièrement gratuit et entièrement
confidentiel
je pense également à des dispositifs
d'aidé à distance dans l'espèce à drogue
info service.fr
devenu un site de référence à cet égard
ou encore à d'autres démarches locales
évidemment dont vous êtes que vous êtes
nombreux à connaître à encourager voire
à avoir été à l'heure à leur initiative
c'est en agissant via donc cette
pluralité de canaux que nous arriverons
à véritablement protéger nos concitoyens
de danger que trop souvent ils ignorent
ou minimisent alors ne relâchons pas
notre vigilance et je remercie une fois
encore la sénatrice les tares de la
sienne de vigilance je remercie
l'ensemble de la représentation
nationale du soutien qu'elle a apporté à
ce texte qui va maintenant pouvoir
effectivement entrés rapidement et
pleinement en vigueur
je vous remercie merci monsieur le
ministre haché invite maintenant madame
jocelyne guide aux rapporteurs de la
commission des affaires sociales à
prendre la parole pour sept minutes
chers collègues
madame la présidente monsieur le
ministre mes chers collègues
c'est en grande partie grâce à valérie
létard que tout le monde le sait
désormais l'usagé tournée du protoxyde
d'azoté à des fins récréatives et d'une
pratique dangereuse au succès inquiétant
est d'autant plus dangereuse que ceux
qui s'y livrent ignore sa dangerosité et
son succès d'autant plus inquiétants qui
concerne essentiellement les mineurs et
les jeunes nageurs la proposition de loi
tendant à prévenir les usages dangereux
du protoxyde d'azoté ainsi que les
députés l'ont rebaptisé n'a jamais eu si
près d'entrer en vigueur
et je suis convaincu qu'elle permettra
de lutter efficacement contre ce fléau
d'abord la vente de ce produit sera
mieux encadré puisque interdire aux
mineurs ainsi qu'aux majeurs dans les
débits de boisson et débits de tabac la
vente des ustensiles liés à l'usagé
récréatif du gaz sera également
interdite
une quantité maximale de vente aux
particuliers soient fixées par arrêté
conjoint des ministres chargés de
l'économie et de la santé
ensuite la prévention sera renforcée par
la mention obligatoire sur les
contenants du gaz la dangerosité de son
usage détourné et par le renforcement
des modules de prévention aux conduites
addictives organisée dans le cadre
scolaire
enfin parce qu'il faut enrayer la
propagation de ce qui est vu bien à tort
comme un loisir anodin la provocation
d'un mineur à faire un usage détourné du
protoxyde d'azoté et plus largement de
tout produit pour en obtenir des effets
psychoactifs sera pénalisé nous pouvons
sans doute regretté que l'assemblée
nationale ait renoncé à la mise à
contribution des intermédiaires
numériques dans la prévention des usages
gens dangereux en supprimant un article
jugé ambigu nous pouvons sans doute
déploré que le gouvernement n'ait pas
souhaité étendre le délit de provocation
aux majeurs également nous pourrions
encore regretté que la traduction de
vente n'est pas été étendu aux stations
service comme cela avait été proposé en
séance publique par les députés ou pas
la question de la consommation de
protoxyde d azote au volant n'est pas
été abordés à cela se poser des
arguments juridiques pratiques ou
politique mais au fond sans doute le
mieux est il l'ennemi du bien
et pour bien faire les grand temps que
ces premières dispositions s'appliquent
ce texte a en effet été déposée au sénat
en avril 2019
nous avons adopté à l'unanimité en
décembre 2019 il a été adopté par
l'assemblée nationale à l'unanimité
encore en mars 2021
avant de nous revenir deux mois plus
tard il aura ainsi fallu plus de deux
ans oui chers collègues pour que
l'encadrement minimale d'un produit à la
dangerosité avérée puisse entrer en
vigueur il faudra encore un peu de temps
avant que la commission européenne ne
donne son autorisation à de telles
restrictions des changes d'un produit de
consommation courante
cela se comprend et je ne plaide assuré
non pas contre le temps de la réflexion
parlementaire mais peut-être
aurions-nous pu tirer plutôt au plus
vite les conséquences qui s'imposaient
de l'observation d'un phénomène de mode
que les britanniques notamment
connaissent bien depuis de nombreuses
années déjà
car en attendant l'usagé récréatif de ce
gaz est à présent devenu à seulement
comme un autre d'économie des
stupéfiants avec ses grossistes a visé
ces intermédiaires spécialisés et son
marketing agressif quoi qu'il en soit
cet ex permettra de lui porté les
premiers coups
réjouissons nous que le gouvernement se
soit rangée à l'analyse que la voyante
de valérie létard remercions valérie six
et nos collègues députés pour leur
remarquable contribution à l'efficacité
du dispositif
et selon le travail des élus locaux qui
reste bien sûr en première ligne dans le
maintien de l'ordre public
la satisfaction l'emportent donc sur les
regrets mais c'est encore une
satisfaction inquiète car alors que nous
sortons péniblement d'une situation de
crise sanitaire sans précédent et que
les alertes sur la santé mentale des
jeunes se multiplient nous pouvons sans
doute les empêcher dans une certaine
mesure de se détruire et de détruire
leur santé
contribuer à leur bonheur est ce un défi
d'une autre ampleur je vous remercie
pour votre attention
merci chers collègues j'appelle à
présent monsieur jean pierre grand au
nom des républicains pour cinq minutes
bonjour sa collègue madame la présidente
monsieur le ministre mama payant de la
commission a mal à porter quelle mère
qu'elle membres des forces de l'ordre
quels enseignants n'ont pas entendu
parler des cartouches dit de gaz ilham
et constater les innombrables cartouches
usagées qui changent l'espace public
originellement utilisé comme gaz de
pression de pressurisation d'un aérosol
alimentaire le protoxyde d azote aux
effets euphorisants est aujourd'hui
massivement utilisé comme drogue
récréative par les jeunes
cette nouvelle mode constitue un réel
échange rien d'un danger pour leur santé
l'évolution de ces pratiques
s'accompagne en effet d'une augmentation
du nombre de signalements d'effets
sanitaires graves avec des atteinte du
système nerveux central et de la moelle
épinière comme l'ont souligné les
experts de l'agencé nationale de santé
l'occitanie figure parmi les trois
régions qui comptent le plus dans toxic
à sion au gaz il avant l'été dernier le
monde est partant de l'hérault des
communes en particulier toral avait
connu durant la saison touristique une
valve de violences graves et une hausse
importante des incivilités des
comportements intolérables souvent
causés par cette image détournée du
protoxyde d'azoté un certain nombre de
maires avaient aussi dû prendre dans le
cadre de leur pouvoir de police des
arrêtés municipaux interdisant
l'utilisation de ces gaz dans l'espace
public afin d'apporter une réponse
concrète à cette réalité de terrain qui
alerte le plus en plus les acteurs
locaux élus professionnels de santé mais
aussi les forces de l'autre nous avons
adopté à l'unanimité le 11 décembre 2019
la proposition de loi présentée par
notre excellente collègue valérie létard
et plusieurs autres sénateurs de groupes
politiques différents tendant à protéger
les mineurs des usages dangereux de ces
deux sets
cette drogue qu'il faut l'appeler par
son nom j'avais proposé deux amendement
qui avait été adopté par la commission
des affaires sociales et je vous en
remercie vraiment le président d'une
part à interdire la vente de protoxyde
d'azoté par des sites de commerce
électronique et d'autre part de
dispenser une formation sur les risques
sur la santé sont usage détourné dans
les établissements scolaires l'assemblée
nationale a adopté ce texte à
l'unanimité le 26 mars dernier preuve
d'un large consensus sur ce sujet c'est
exaltant modifier le code de la santé
publique en prévoyant que le fait de
provoquer un mineur à faire un usage
détourné d'un produit de consommation
courante tels que le proto europe pour
en obtenir des essais ainsi qu'aux
actifs sera désormais impuni de 15000
euros d'amande
de même il sera interdit de vendre ou
d'offrir un mineur du protoxyde d'azoté
quel qu'en soit le conditionnement les
sites de commerce en ligne devront
spécifié interdiction de la vente aux
mineurs de ce produit sur les pages
permettant de procéder à l'achat en lit
par ailleurs une mention indiquant la
dangerosité de l'usagé tournée il faut
aussi des réseaux sera apposée sur
chaque unité de consommer encore il
avait bien précisé valoir le rapporteur
de plus je me félicite que le texte
concerne la mesure du renforcement de la
prévention dans le cadre scolaire
informations dispensées dans
l'établissement scolaire déjà prévus
pour la consommation de drogues devra
ainsi inclure les dangers de l'usagé
détourné du protoxyde d'azoté
enfin comme l'a souligné la rapporteur
au nom de la commission je tiens dans je
tiens à saluer le travail
je regrette l'absence d'obligation
d'information des internautes
au moment de l'achat de ces produits
c'est le ministre je fais le voeu qu'une
réponse puisse être apportée dans un
futur proche
face au double problème que pose usage
détourné de ce gaz il a à la fois en
matière de santé publique et le maintien
de l'ordre
nous ne pouvons que nous féliciter que
cette proposition de loi de valérie
car puisse être adoptée aujourd'hui
définitivement par notre assemblée
vous l'aurez compris le groupe
républicain votera en faveur de ce texte
merci monsieur le sénateur jean vie de
maintenant monsieur à la marque à
prendre la parole au nom des
indépendants pour cinq minutes
merci madame la présidente monsieur le
ministre
même la présidente de la commission soit
porteur chers collègues notre assemblée
examina nouvelle lecture la proposition
de loi présentée par valérie létard
visant à prévenir des usages dangereux
du protoxyde d'azoté
ce produit peut être achetée pour une
somme modique par n'importe qui un
supermarché bureau de tabac ou sur
internet
sa facilité d'accès ajouté à la
publicité de sur ses effets hilarant
diffusés sur les réseaux sociaux ont
popularisé un usage détourné comme un
produits récréatifs et festif chez les
mineurs de plus en plus jeunes si la
proposition de loi cible plus
particulièrement les mineurs la moyenne
d'âge des consommateurs et de 21 ans sa
consommation souvent en groupe peut
aller jusqu'à 200 capsules par jour
le gaz à une action immédiate et agit
sur une courte durée
la plupart des consommateurs ignorent
les conséquences de cette drogue
souvent prises en association avec de
l'alcool ou d'autres stupéfiants
les centres antipoison reportant des
risques d' asphyxie de coma et
d'atteintes neurologiques et
neuromusculaires grave hein le principal
problème c'est la facilité avec laquelle
les jeunes consommateurs ont la
possibilité d'acheter ce gas en achetant
des siphon à chantilly commercialisé
librement en magasin et sur internet
en effet son utilisation n'est soumise à
aucune restriction
en dehors de quelques arrêtés municipaux
dont la portée reste
limiter le texte que nous examinons
entend combler ce vide juridique pour
protéger le jeune public des
intoxications au protoxyde d'azoté
le coeur du texte vise à interdire la
vente de gaz hilarant aux mineurs et à
pénaliser l incitation de mineurs à en
faire un usage détourné des éléments
d'information sur la dangerosité du
produit seront désormais obligatoirement
visible sur les emballages ainsi que sur
chaque siphon par ailleurs la
proposition de loi prévoit une campagne
de sensibilisation spécifiques en milieu
scolaire étendu à l'ensemble des
pratiques addictives l'assemblée
nationale a contribué à enrichir les
dispositions du texte en étendant
l'interdiction de vendre du protoxyde
d'azoté aux mineurs à tous les lieux
ainsi qu'au ballon et objets dédiés à
cette consommation détourner ces
dispositions vont permettre de protéger
une partie des consommateurs des risques
liés à la consommation de cette
substance
je rappellerai ni à moins que la moyenne
d'âge des consommateurs et de 21 ans
aussi cette proposition de loi ne sera
pas suffisante pour réduire les usages
et prévenir les risques notamment chez
les jeunes majeurs l'interdiction du
produit se heurterait au droit européen
mais nous pouvons utilement à limiter le
nombre de cartouches que peut acheter un
particulier comme la file danemark
confronté au même problème en parallèle
de ces mesures
à ces mesures par dont nous devons
renforcer les moyens de lutte contre du
trafic illégal ces derniers mois deux
réseaux de trafic de gaz hilarant ont
été démantelés en seine saint denis
comme soulignant commission la
prévention des addictions reste un volet
essentiel pour protéger les mineurs et
les jeunes adultes de pratiques
dangereuses en lien avec les
associations de terrain
enfin face au développement de la vente
des produits stupéfiants sur les réseaux
sociaux et sur les messageries privées
nous devons mettre en oeuvre un
accompagnement à la parentalité à
travers le numérique
le groupe les indépendants république et
territoires soutient pleinement cette
démarche et votera en faveur de cette
proposition de loi
merci chers collègues
mais j'invite maintenant madame raymonde
poncet manche du groupe écologiste à
s'exprimer pour un temps de 5 minutes
chers collègues madame la présidente
monsieur le ministre madame n'a pas
porter mes chers collègues
bien que centré sur la prévention des
usages dangereux du protoxyde d azote
cette proposition de loi s'avère plus
générique et pourra s'appliquer à tous
mes usages d'un produit de consommation
courante pour la recherche des effets
psychoactifs adoptée à l'unanimité par
nous deux assemblées elle marque des
avancées certaines quant à la prévention
de cette conduites addictives qui
progresse quelquefois parallèlement un
autre produit du fait de sa facilité
d'accès de son faible coût et de sa
soi-disant innocuité cela inquiète les
professionnels de santé les pouvoirs
publics et les élus locaux
d'autant que cela touche un public de
plus en plus jeunes
en 2018 l'observatoire français des
drogues et des toxicomanies alertait car
la consommation se banalise est en
parfaite méconnaissance des risques
associés en matière de santé immédiats
comme des pertes de connaissance sud où
est fixé et en cas de consommation
récurrentes comme des complications
neurologiques ou des carences en
vitamine b12 les élus et les
associations observe la banalisation de
cet usage récréatif dans la visibilité
se manifestent effectivement parler de
cette capsule métallique lors de
rencontres festives de festivals et même
de soirée médecine à lyon bordeaux paris
il n'est pas rare de voir des bars à
proto ou les jeunes achètent directement
des ballons à côté de deby de poissons
ou basso en février le centre d'un
dicton vigilance de lyon et la rs
appeler un nouvelle campagne de
sensibilisation sur les risques encourus
par les jeunes consommateurs
suite je cite à la récente recrudescence
au niveau de la métropole lyonnaise des
signalements d'atteintes neurologiques
ainsi que de la présence vie
hymne de bonbonnes dans l'espace public
pour le centre d'accueil et
d'accompagnement à la réduction des
risques pour usagers de drogue de lyon
lusage installés depuis longtemps est
aujourd'hui plus fréquents
originellement festif il est devenu
solitaire ou en petits groupes et les
étudiants pris en charge étaient pour la
plupart déjà consommateurs au lycée
voire au collège cette situation appelée
donc une régulation c'est l'objet de ce
texte en encadrant la vente de ce gaz y
compris pour les publics majeurs
cette proposition de loi apporte une
réponse aux élus locaux
démuni face à ce problème de santé
publique il ne sera plus nécessaire en
effet que des maires prennent des
arrêtés d'interdiction qui ne relevaient
pas de leur compétence et idées lors ne
pouvait être efficace
néanmoins précisons que les
interdictions ne font pas tout et le
texte heureusement ne s'y limite pas
usage de ce produit n'est pas que
ponctuelle pour septembre s'est installé
une véritable dépendance aux produits
d'ailleurs la progression des
signalements sanitaires durant la crise
du coc vide alerte sur une conduite
devenu addictives pour une partie des
usagers
pour cela ce qui est essentiel de
traiter c'est la relation qu'ils
entretiennent avec le produit
au delà du produit lui-même qui peut
être substituée aussi cela doit
s'inscrire dans une politique ambitieuse
de prévention et de réduction des
risques est d'autant contenu des
conséquences sur la santé mentale de la
crise sanitaire le portugal qui a
décriminalisé en 2000 la consommation
individuelle de toutes les drogues et
privilégier l'accompagnement à la
sanction a obtenu des résultats
concluants cette politique s'avère un
succès les associations de terrain
appelle à multiplier les solutions de
prévention et d'accompagnement des
consommateurs
bien notamment la mise en place de
structures spécialisées et un suivi
social renforcé aussi nous saluons
l'equilibre de ce texte qui appuie sur
la prévention et l'information ou lié à
l'étiquetage et sur des actions de
sensibilisation en milieu scolaire sur
les risques de ces consommations
nous resterons attentifs aux moyens
accordés à la politique de prévention et
de réduction des risques
aussi considérant qu'il s'agit d'une
réponse nécessaire et équilibré a un
problème de santé publique
le groupe écologiste solidarité et
territoires
votre à ce texte je vous remercie merci
chers collègues
j'appelle à présent madame nicole
duranton à s'exprimer au nom du groupe r
des pays pour cinq minutes s'il vous
plaît bonjour
merci madame la présidente monsieur le
ministre
madame la rapporteure chers collègues un
grand merci à valérie létard de
s'emparer de ce sujet essentiel
beaucoup de choses ont déjà été dites et
je vais le répéter le protoxyde d'azoté
est à l'origine un gaz à usage médical
utilisé pour ses propriétés analgésiques
il sert également comme propulseur pour
les siphon à chantilly ce produit bon
marché est en vente libre sur internet
et dans le commerce
cependant le protoxyde d'azoté n2o est
surtout connue de nos jeunes comme le
proto un gaz hilarant à effets
euphorisants son usage détourné consiste
à inhalé le gaz par le biais d'un ballon
après avoir craqué la cartouche pour
l'ouvrir malheureusement cette
consommation n'est pas sans risque
l'inhalation du protoxyde d azote peut
provoquer des brûlures une asphyxie voir
une perte de connaissance des
intoxications des effets cliniques
principalement neurologiques allant
jusqu'à des atteintes de la moelle
épinière
mais aussi cardiaque et psychiatriques
l'arrêté du 17 août 2001 l'inscrit sur
la liste un des substances vénéneuses
il est ensuite soumis à une
réglementation stricte par l'arrêté du
21 décembre 2001 pour lutter contre ce
fléau
les pouvoirs publics français alerte sur
la nécessité de conduire des actions de
sensibilisation actuellement seul le
détournement du protoxyde d'azoté à
usage médical est encadrée par la loi
en revanche celui à usage domestique
n'est soumis à aucune restriction
le texte que nous examinons aujourd'hui
vise à corriger ce vide juridique depuis
2010 scène de nombreuses petites
cartouches grise contenant ce gaz sont
retrouvés dans l'espace public comme le
souligne le rapport de l'observatoire
français des drogues et de toxicomanie
bouclier en décembre 2018
ce phénomène traduit une banalisation de
sa consommation qui selon une étude de
la mutuelle smerep mais troisième
produit psychoactif le plus consommé
chez les jeunes les collectivités
locales s'investissent déjà
fortement dans la prévention par exemple
dans mon département de l'eure le maire
de vernon françois ouzilleau ap en 2020
un arrêté municipal
cet arrêté prévoit d'interdire la vente
ou le don de cartouches ou de tout autre
récipient contenant du protoxyde d'azoté
à une personne mineurs non accompagnés
d'un adulte
une amende de 68 euros est prévue pour
la détention
l'utilisation et le dépôt de cartouches
dans l'espace public
cela fait peser plusieurs mois que la
police municipale de vernon les services
de la voirie et de la propreté urbaine
constater la recrudescence de cartouches
au sol dans l'espace public
au delà du risque de santé publique
elles sont également une pollution
environnementale critique voté à
l'unanimité en première lecture à
l'assemblée nationale
les éléments essentiels de cette
proposition de loi issue du sénat ont
été adoptées notamment l'interdiction de
vente aux mineurs de produits contenant
du protoxyde d'azoté et la pénalisation
de l'incitation d'un mineur à faire
usage détourné en commission des
affaires sociales et en séance plusieurs
amendements ont été adoptés renforçant
les mesures initiales du texte
je pense à la vente de créateurs
l'étiquetage danger sur le produit et
des précisions pour la mise en oeuvre du
texte à wallis et futuna
il s'agit également de mobiliser les
agents de police municipale aux actions
de prévention
depuis juillet 2010 9 sous l'impulsion
conjointe du ministère chargé de la
santé et celui de l'éducation nationale
l'ensemble des collèges et lycées de
france met en place progressivement des
partenariats avec des consultations
jeunes consommateurs proposant aux
jeunes et à leur entourage
un service d'écouté et d'orientation
totalement gratuit et confidentiel
une campagne d'information de la mission
interministérielle de lutte contre les
drogues et les conduites addictives vise
à doter les acteurs de terrain
associations et collectivités locales de
supports de sensibilisation claire et
adaptée
la présente proposition de loi a aussi
pour objet de renforcer la prévention et
la meilleure information des jeunes dans
les établissements scolaires sur les
risques de l'usaj
détourner du n2o la milles d'écart a
lancé en juin 2020 une campagne sur les
réseaux sociaux
monsieur le ministre quelles sont les
nouvelles mesures supplémentaires
envisagées sur internet pour informer
les jeunes des risques de l' usage
détourné du n2o sur leur santé pour
conclure le protoxyde d'azoté représente
sous ses airs ligier un véritable danger
pour nos jeunes
ce texte englobe l'ensemble des aspects
d'une prévention efficiente et d'une
dissuasion nécessaires pour protéger les
mineurs l'importance de cette
proposition de loi est partagé par tous
plusieurs sénateurs de mon groupe et moi
même étions d'ailleurs co signataires de
ce texte
compte tenu de ces éléments et du
souhait d'une mise en oeuvre rapide des
dispositifs prévus par le texte
mon groupe r des pays votre à en faveur
du texte issu de la commission et au
profit d'une adoption conforme
merci chers collègues j'invite à présent
madame véronique guillotin à prendre la
parole au nom de son groupe du
rassemblement démocratique et social
européen pour cinq minutes chers
collègues
madame la présidente monsieur le
ministre collègues alors que le mésusage
du protoxyde d'azoté connaît une
recrudescence une recrudescence dans
notre pays depuis 2010 est nous voici
réunis ici afin d'examiner en deuxième
lecture une proposition de loi plus que
nécessaire et je voudrais saluer
l'auteur de la proposition
valérie létard le confinement accru la
survenue de comportements addictifs dans
leur ensemble y compris usage détourné
du protoxyde d azote comme le relève le
réseau national l'addictologue
d'addictovigilance dans son bulletin de
novembre 2020 le déconfinement lui a eu
pour effet de le rendre plus visible son
usage occasionnant divers troubles à
l'ordre public à la tranquillité à la
salubrité à la sécurité causés par le
bruit l'abandon de cartouches et de
ballons dans les rues ou encore tout
récemment l'explosion d'une voiture
occupée par cinq adolescents qui
consommaient du protoxyde d'azoté de
nombreux maires nous alerte sur la
situation régulièrement et pour certains
ils ont pris des arrêtés interdisant la
consommation ou la vente de protoxyde
sur leur territoire
tout ceci sans véritable effet
l'assemblée nationale a adhéré à
l'économie générale du texte et a décidé
de maintenir en grande partie des
éléments introduits par le sénat avec le
groupe
rds je m'en réjouis elle a toutefois
adopté plusieurs modifications à
l'article 2 avec introduction d'un
plafonnement de la quantité maximale de
protoxyde d azote pouvant être vendus
aux particuliers quantité qui sera fixée
par arrêté conjoint des ministres
chargés de la santé et de l'économie
une mesure qui va certes dans le bon
sens il convient toutefois de s'assurer
que la restriction posée n'est pas
excessive au regard de l'objectif
poursuivi est comme l'a rappelé la
rapporteure jocelyne bidez l'arrêté
ministériel ne pourrait être prise
qu'après un avis de la commission
européenne le seuil sera par ailleurs
déterminé au terme d'une réflexion
conjointe ainsi et ainsi que tout désolé
par une décision conjointe tous ces
éléments devraient bien évidemment
en sorte que la quantité d'encre
conserve un plafonnement raisonnable
l'assemblée nationale a également élargi
l'interdiction de vente ou d'offre du
protoxyde d'azoté aux personnes majeures
haut débit de boisson temporaires
cette extension de l'interdiction au
delà des débits de boisson initialement
visés nous semble pertinent est conforme
à l'esprit du texte tout comme
l'interdiction de la vente ou
distribution de tout produit
spécifiquement destinés à faciliter
l'extraction de protoxyde d'azoté afin
d'en obtenir des effets psychoactifs
l'article 2 apporte en outre une
clarification c'est bien la dangerosité
de l' usage détourné du protoxyde et non
usage du gaz en lui même qui doit faire
l'objet d'un étiquetage dédié sur chaque
unité conditionnement en effet dans ses
comptes dans des conditions normales le
gaz intervient dans des usages médicaux
culinaires et industriels qu'il faut
bien évidemment préserver ce même
article prévoit la constatation des
infractions aux interdictions de vente
pourrait être aussi réalisé par les
agents de police municipale
les gardes champêtres ainsi que les
agents de surveillance
cette extension va certes dans le bon
sens encore faut-il que les forces de
l'ordre soient présentes en effectif
suffisant ce qui n'est pas le cas dans
bon nombre de territoires
l'article 2 bis qui permettait de
renforcer les obligations qu'ont les
intermédiaires numériques d'informer les
interdictions de vente aux mineurs de
certains produits a été supprimé par les
députés
nous déplorons car l'information la
responsabilisation des usagers restent
en santé
la première des priorités enfin les
députés ont intitulé le texte auparavant
en modifier l'intitulé du texte
auparavant proposition de loi tendant à
protéger les mineurs des usages
dangereux du protoxyde d'azoté il tend
désormais à prévenir les usages
dangereux du protoxyde d'azoté de
manière plus élargie en atteignant les
jeunes majeurs nous ne pouvons
qu'accueillir favorablement ce progrès
cette proposition de loi constitue une
belle avancée que nous saluons sans
réserve
elles constituent elles contribuent à la
sensibilisation des jeunes sur les
conduites à 10
yves elle permet d'informer sur la
dangerosité de ce produit détourné de
son usage
elle punit la provocation d'un mineur à
faire usage détourné du produit de
consommation courante pour en obtenir
des effets psychoactifs et interdit la
vente et l'offre à des mineurs dans les
commerces physiques comme les commerces
en ligne détourné un produit
consommation de son usage est une
pratique qui ne concerne pas seulement
le protoxyde d'azoté et malheureusement
l'innovation en la matière est sans
limite
nous ne pouvons qu'appeler le
gouvernement à aller encore plus loin
dans le domaine de la prévention
l'aide à la parentalité la
sensibilisation dès le plus jeune âge
pour l'heure est au regarde l'équilibré
trouvé par ce texte le groupe rds votera
en faveur de cette proposition de loi
avec enthousiasme et sans réserve
bonjour merci chers collègues j'invite
maintenant madame cathy apourceau poly
du groupe communiste à prendre la parole
pour cinq minutes
merci madame la présidente monsieur le
ministre
madame la présidente de rade commission
excusez moi madame la rapporteure mes
chers collègues le protoxyde d'azoté
autrefois limitée à certains milieux
notamment les facs de médecine est
devenu une triste banalité
nombreuses sont les villes avoir des
cartouches jonchaient les trottoirs
ce phénomène touche particulièrement la
région des hauts de france mais concerne
l'ensemble du territoire national et un
public de plus en plus jeunes
la consommation se banalise
plus que jamais il nous faut donc alerté
dès le plus jeune âge
nous le savons l'expérimentation dans un
premier temps peut s'avérer et se
transformer chez ces jeunes en solutions
du mal être et peut devenir le moyen
pour supporter une période difficile
nous venons de la vivre cette période
difficile et elle peut être propice à
cela est évidemment dans tous les
milieux
plus que jamais il nous faut donc
favoriser la prévention
aujourd'hui des sites de commerce en
ligne ne font même plus semblant de
destiner ses cartouches à l'affût
fabrication de chantilly en proposant
des laudes aux bonbonnes de grande
capacité
c'est comme moi vous faites l'expérience
d'effectuer une recherche sur internet
en tapant gaz hilarant une alerte
publicitaire cette affiche et indiquant
oublier les soirées ennuyeuses
essayez le gaz hilarant livraison à
domicile en 30 minutes
notre épicerie vous garantit une soirée
pleine de fou rire dans les produits ils
proposent des tanks de 4 litres à 150
euros alors que pouvons nous faire
en tant que parlementaire face à ce
détournement d'un produit de
consommation alimentaire notre collègue
valérie létard dont je tiens à saluer
l'engagement sur ce sujet a proposé
d'agir en créant une interdiction de la
vente de protoxyde d'azoté au mineure
est un délit de provocation des mineurs
nous sommes favorables à ces mesures de
répression si un équilibre est maintenu
avec des mesures de prévention
les mesures de restriction sont
nécessaires mais parfois inefficaces si
elles ne sont pas accompagnées d'une
politique de prévention offensive
l'outil le plus efficace pour
sensibiliser les jeunes sur les effets
du gaz hilarant et son usage demeure à
discours de santé publique qui informe
sur les risques de la consommation de ce
gaz en faisant appel à des jeunes formés
sur les risques du protoxyde d'azoté qui
vont à la rencontre d'autres jeunes sur
les lieux de consommation connues des
jeunes qui s'adressent à d'autres jeunes
avec un message d'information sur les
risques sans stigmatisation a fait ses
preuves sur le vih par exemple c'est la
raison pour laquelle nous demandons au
gouvernement de soutenir cette
proposition de loi
en inscrivant dès le projet de loi de
finances rectificative 2021
une ligne budgétaire pour financer une
campagne nationale de prévention contre
l'usagé du protoxyde d'azoté
sans l'impulsion nationale du ministère
de la santé et du ministère de
l'éducation nationale le gouvernement
ferait la démonstration du peu d'intérêt
qu'ils portent à nos jeunes
en conclusion le groupe communiste
républicain citoyen et écologistes devra
va te ra pour cette proposition de loi
comme nous l'avions fait en première
lecture
je vous remercie
merci chers collègues j'appelle
maintenant bernard jomier à s'exprimer
pour le groupe socialiste pour cinq
minutes
bonjour chers collègues présidente
monsieur le ministre madame la
présidente de la commission madame le
rapporteur mes chers collègues à ce
stade de nos discussions je vais dans un
premier temps dire que je souscris à aux
propos qui ont été tenus par mes
collègues et je l'en remercie valérie
létard effectivement d'avoir présenté ce
texte utile que nous avions voté en
première lecture il n'y a pas de
suspense nous le voterons également en
seconde lecture le protoxyde d azote wii
est un problème et moi j'étais très très
marquée de voir cette étude faite à
l'université de bordeaux quand même sur
plus de dix mille étudiants où on
apprend que 13 % d'entre eux sont des
consommateurs actifs et que plus de 25 %
qu'on consomme et du protoxyde d azote
et ça dit bien l'ampleur du problème et
2e donner encore plus récente il ya
quinze jours à rosny sous bois une
saisie a été effectuée 2218 bouteilles
de protoxyde d azote 1218 bouteille ça
dit je crois
l'ampleur du problème et l'organisation
de réseaux de réseaux très bien
organisée qui trouvent là une source de
revenus en plus bien moins risqué
pénalement que le trafic d'autres
substances
alors oui il faut commencer encadrer
plus strictement et ça n'est pas simple
car il s'agit par ailleurs non pas d'un
produit légal mais d'un produit autorisé
et donc je remercie encore une fois
notre collègue valérie létard de cet
atelier
à cette tâche mais comme je lé j'ai eu
l'occasion de le dire lors de nos
travaux en commission une approche par
produit et tout le monde en conviendra
ne peut être suffisante et satisfaisante
cette proposition de loi est nécessaire
utile elle ne peut pas être suffisante
c'est bien la politique des addictions
de notre pays qui est interrogé et quand
on écoute les dernières déclarations en
la matière moi la dernière j'ai entendu
d'un ministre c'est le ministre de
l'intérieur qui a déclaré la drogue
c'est de la merde on le remercie pour sa
contribution à la résolution du problème
le ministre de la santé
actuellement beaucoup d'occupations donc
ne s'est pas exprimée récemment mais
lorsqu'il était député il était un
député actif sur ces questions et qui a
porté qui a supporté des dispositifs
intéressant et puis enfin nous vivons
sur le plan actuellement 2018 2022
le plan national de mobilisation contre
les addictions plan qui trouve une
application va dire inégale et je me
rappelle que l'amp acquis maintenant
d'abeilles d'ailleurs s'appelle
l'addiction france lorsque ce plan avait
été publiée avait dit c'est un bon plan
avec beaucoup d'intentions qui sont
bonnes mais malheureusement il n'a ni
calendrier de finances ni calendrier ni
financement ni outils d'évaluation
c'était de mémoire les propos exacts de
cette grande association de lutte contre
les addictions et malheureusement c'est
ce qui est en train de se passer et
notamment notamment sur un domaine dans
un domaine qui est extrêmement important
qui est celui du lien de la politique
des addictions avec la politique de
santé mentale
nous avons plusieurs fois depuis un an
parler de ce thème important et la
nécessité de renforcer la politique de
notre pays en la matière les dispositifs
de santé mentale sont largement
insuffisants et pour une part inopérant
en matière de lutte contre l'addiction
et c'est une interrogation qui nous
adresser collectivement
quand je regarde la situation dans mon
département à paris dans le nord-est
parisien grandes zones de consommation
de crack dispositif qui fonctionne mal
disons le c'est très compliqué il a
fallu que les riverains excédés sortent
des mortiers et tir à coups de mortier
sont les usagers de drogues présent dans
la rue pour que le préfet décide de
réagir et au fond de déplacer les
usagers de drogues dans un jardin public
un peu plus loin mais tant que nous
n'aurons pas ces dispositifs de santé
mentale sociaux aussi et
d'accompagnement nous ne résoudront rien
du tout et je crains je crains que la
situation dans ce quartier de paris soit
un peu à l'image de notre politique
nationale en la matière nous en avons la
connaissance théorique
nous nous avons des outils que nous
pouvons plus ou moins utilisé et au fond
peut-être occupé à autre chose nous nous
consacrons pas suffisamment l'énergie
nécessaire donc merci pour ce premier
pas énergique nous retrouvons ce texte
merci chers collègues enfin j'invite la
présidente valérie l'état à s'exprimer
au nom de son groupe mais surtout comme
auteurs de cette proposition de loi
merci madame la présidente madame la
présidente madame la présidente de la
commission des affaires sociales
monsieur le ministre
madame le rapporteur mes chers collègues
tout d'abord je tiens bien sûr à vous
faire part du du plaisir de la
satisfaction que j'ai de voir
aujourd'hui a beau tir notre travail
collectif parce que c'est véritablement
d'un travail collectif qu'il s'agit
alors ce travail bien sûr il
rivas à la mise en place d'un dispositif
aptes à lutter contre les effets
néfastes de l'uzège détourner du
protoxyde d azote ou gaz hilarant un
long chemin a été parcouru depuis notre
première alerte le 6 février 2019 lors
d'une question d'actualité au
gouvernement monsieur le ministre vous y
étiez
et cette alerte en fait elle nous
venaient de qui nous elle nous venaient
des mères puisque ce sont de nombreux
maires du département du nord à l'époque
au travers de l'association des maires
qui avait alerté mon attention sur cette
question parce que ont commencé à
trouver en tout point du territoire et
pas seulement dans la métropole de lille
mais aussi dans des petites communes
périurbaines
cette présence de capsules un peu
partout sur le territoire et c'est bien
parce qu'il ya eu cette réalité concrète
de terrain à une impuissance les élus
locaux que nous en sommes venus à en
débattre au début quelques
interrogations monsieur le ministre sur
la portée et la nécessité de légiférer
parce que ce sujet était encore
confidentiel à ce moment là et qu'il
était peut-être plus territorialisée et
puis on s'est rendu compte que très
rapidement en fait sa consommation elle
s'est étendue en tout point du
territoire national à la flambée elle
encore monter en puissance c'est vrai
avec l'arrivée du confinement et vous
l'avez rappelé au travers des dernières
enquêtes récentes au travers de deux
commandes analyse sur nombre d'étudiants
en université mais on le sait aussi des
remontées de collèges deux lycées en de
différentes sphères qui montrent
qu'effectivement il est urgent
maintenant de légiférer et ça me permet
aussi de vous dire monsieur le ministre
est de dire et de rappeler combien si
nous avions un peu plus d espace
d'initiative parlementaire
eh bien peut-être nous irions plus vite
sur un certain nombre de sujets comme
ceux ci puisqu'il a salué un premier
texte effectivement voté en décembre
2019 puis ensuite ça a été rappelé et il
y a trois mois en mars dernier pour
arriver aujourd'hui grâce à la
législation en commission et un travail
en commun et je remercie effectivement
valérie six et tous les députés de
toutes sensibilités qui se sont
mobilisés nous avons réussi enfin à
venir à bout de tout ce travail
parlementaire qui effectivement prend un
certain temps mais le résultat est au
rendez vous alors je le rappellerai que
brièvement ça a été dit par les uns et
les autres
notre rédaction initiale a su élaborer
un socle et je remercie madame la
rapporteure je suis guide est ce parce
que elle a introduit avec la commission
une notion nouvelle qui servira je pense
pour l'avenir qui permet de créer un
délit d'incitation d'un mineur à faire
un usage détourné d'un produit de
consommation courante est comme ça a été
rappelé ça ne se limite pas au protoxyde
d'azoté
mais à bien d'autres produits qui peut
être un jour arriveront sur le marché de
façon détournée et nous aurons des
premiers outils effectivement pour
commencer à traiter de cette question
l'interdiction de vente et de la session
l'obligation d'étiquetage de sa
dangerosité ou encore bien évidemment
une information en milieu scolaire et ça
a été rappelée travail est sanctionnée
c'est bien mais si nous n'avons pas pris
tout un arsenal de dispositions pour
informer prévenir accompagnée évidemment
y compris en ligne monsieur grands et
vous y avait contribué
tout cela est bien nous constituera pas
l'arsenal suffisant pour pouvoir être
efficace
alors là semblait effectivement a nourri
ce travail a étendu la protection à nos
jeunes majeurs en interdisant la vente
de produits facilitant aussi
l'extraction en limitant la quantité
maximale ouvertes à la vente
parce que là aussi on le voit est bien
quand on commence à acheter un nombre
significatif de capsules
c'est certainement pas pour en faire de
la chantilly on le sait bien
de la même façon que quand on achète un
cracker ou des ballons de baudruche ça
n'est pas non plus pour faire de la
chantilly alors que l'on interdise tout
cela est bien évidemment c'est du bon
sens et c'est indispensable
ce qui nous permet aujourd'hui de voter
un texte qui dans sa formule abouti et
définitive offre une base
jce l'atvs adapté à la prévention des
comportements dangereux des mineurs et
des jeunes adultes même si on aimerait
aller plus loin ça a été dit les jeunes
adultes sont ceux qui sont frappés par
les troubles les plus sévères les plus
importants et donc il était important
effectivement de traiter tout cela alors
je vais pas tout vous remercier tous
salués mais monsieur grand madame imbert
madame de seine est évidemment sont
venus conforter le travail de jocelyne
qui a été d'une efficacité absolue
évidemment sur ce travail alors je
remercie les quatorze les 94
cosignataire de l'asd du sénat qui ont
été autant de porte voix et deux
défenseurs de cette loi
aujourd'hui monsieur le ministre eh ben
nous sommes très heureux de vous
retrouver et de nous dire que autour
d'une question de santé publique
eh bien nous avons trouvé un consensus
et de part et d'autre nous avons trouvé
avec le sens de l'intérêt général le
moyen de faire en sorte que cette loi et
nous comptons sur vous monsieur le
ministre pour que les petites parties
qui relève de dispositions
réglementaires aille vite mais très
heureux de faire en sorte que demain nos
élus et tout le monde sur le terrain est
un arsenal législatif opérant qui leur
permette enfin de ne plus avoir recours
à des arrêtés municipaux qui n'était
qu'un cataplasme sur une jambe de bois
il ya deux jours encore la pqr données
informations que quelques communes
prenait des arrêtés
c'est attendu alors maintenant il ne
reste plus qu'à l'appliquer et à le
voter définitivement
merci en tout cas c'est fait c'est voter
déjà excusez moi mais en tout cas merci
beaucoup à vous tous chers collègues
pour ce travail collectif
encore une fois et bravo à vous tous
merci merci madame la présidente merci
surtout pour cette proposition de loi
effectivement très attendu je vais
mettre aux voix dans le texte de la
commission la proposition de loi modifié
par l'assemblée nationale tendant à
prévenir les usages dangereux du
protoxyde d'azoté qui votent pour qu'ils
votent contre qui s'abstient il est voté
à l'unanimité
bravo madame la présidente selon la
formule consacrée la proposition de loi
modifié par l'assemblée nationale
tendance à prévenir les usages dangereux
de protoxyde d'azoté et d'adopter
définitivement
[Musique]